your videos are very stressful yeah like
the Mr Beast one stress me that I felt
stressed watching that one what's the Mr
Beast one yeah you want to explain it I
know do you go ahead again it's your
video
I so I got a i God only it was such a
whole thing that I'm trying to like even
just compare this is like trauma sorry
am I digging up
yeah yes yeah
um
in I thought it was like a year ago they
asked if we wanted to make like a
subscriber counter for them I thought it
was this and the uh the exploding thing
as well it's both oh okay so it kind of
started so I was like yeah like this
sounds fun like you know it'd be like an
introduction to their team and be able
to see how they do stuff yes exactly
mechanical clock that Rose notes right
oh so that was kind of the initial
conversation and then after that a
couple weeks later they're like hey
we're doing this good game thing and I
was like oh like okay like what do you
what do you want what do you need
um and it was it was a lot of time
and basically we needed to build some
sort of like squib system to make it
look like people were being shot yeah
right right
oh okay yeah so they wanted to replicate
the a bunch of scenes from the show yeah
and in order to do that you know what
they do in Hollywood is they'll have
little explosives like that's I think
the actual squib terms for the explosive
charge that propels the like the blood
out yeah right but they can use them for
dirt and stuff so you can bury them in
dirt and cover them during to get like
bullet hits
so what you do on for budget is you kind
of use an air valve you get like a piece
of tube like a sprinkler valve basically
a little air tank out of PVC and you can
like project blood out that way but when
you're talking 500 people yeah like
there's nothing that exists that can do
that right and so we went through this
like nightmare process to essentially
theorize like completely synthesize from
scratch a device that could be
replicated 500 times in basically two
weeks so so yeah so once you found out
about this yeah when you found out about
a project was it two weeks before three
weeks
yeah so that's the exactly people think
three weeks they don't really understand
what that means yeah it would take a
week just to get the idea together yeah
and that's rushing yeah yeah so that was
week one week one was essentially what
people think you have three weeks for is
actually only one week so you have one
week to send something to a company to
have a prototype come back you can
remember in the video there's a lot of
problems with certain companies wouldn't
make certain things
right it was a disaster it was really
bad and it was probably like I don't
like I try to be very like kind of
passive and peaceful when I talk to
people about problems right I lost my
[ __ ] multiple times talking like I was
actually I at one point I was talking to
someone on the phone I like I felt bad
I'm like I don't know if I'm going too
far or not like if I'm just being a
total [ __ ] right now but I was like I
like I literally said like I'm [ __ ]
you [ __ ] us and she was like language
and I was like what do you mean you
[ __ ] us like like I'm speaking English
like you're more worried like they
couldn't fulfill an order or something
they just didn't give a [ __ ]
I had sent them like like 10 grand it
was gonna be like 20 000 and we had sent
the first I think I could get that yeah
I mean if you if you're spending 10
grand yeah and it's like if if I sign up
for something and you tell me it may or
may not happen there's no guarantee it's
gonna cost this much money I'm like okay
you've warned me but when you say that
you're gonna get it done in like three
days and then nothing happens like how
am I not supposed to be pissed oh yeah
yeah you have it every right too yeah so
you had like you had one week of
planning and then two week of I guess
assembling 500. well because that was
like an app as well and all that and
that must have just yeah I want to ask
about it because it seemed like crazy it
was it was hands down type two fun it
was like one of the worst experiences of
my entire life one font uh type one fun
I think where it's actually fun type two
is where it's fun after the facts oh
okay oh okay
yeah that that explains so much there's
so many things I know in the moment I
hated it yeah like that was awesome yeah
is there a type 3 phone I don't know
it's sadness so okay so you how did this
company [ __ ] you and then I remember in
the video there's like some uh some
family yeah own business there's some
small family business that's like really
understands the whole like circuit board
making World they basically intervened
and they helped to handle everything
because they understand how the whole
pipeline works that they understand how
to deal with these companies because it
turns out like half of these PCB
manufacturing companies are in Denver
Colorado right like it's almost like a
that's the trip the board itself yeah
where they make the fiberglasses
um so these guys don't make the
fiberglass because that's like a very
disgusting process and it's like very
yeah it's a whole chemical thing uh and
huge machines like huge huge huge
assembly lines and so these guys
essentially helped us to to intervene
and go to the company that was
originally making them still have them
make the fiberglass because that's the
hardest part to make then intercept them
take them to their small shop where they
would then assemble them which is the
whole secondary process like it it is
like it is such a convoluted process
that does not work well if you have not
enough time to do it like you have to
have almost double the time you need in
order for it to go yeah what was your
first question like why didn't you give
me more notice no I didn't ask them any
questions like I was very blunt with
them that's why I was worried some
people would get upset with the you know
Mr abuse team for asking for something
so it's really crazy but it's like
they had this problem and I said I think
we can do it and I gave him I gave him a
price there's a lot of money and I was
like it's gonna cost an insane amount of
money right because everything we do is
like if you buy something for five
dollars you pay 80 to ship it overnight
yeah like everything is like balls to
the wall whatever is the most expensive
fastest guaranteed and I warned them
that you guys potentially gonna pay us
this money and we're not gonna deliver
you something are you okay with that and
they're like yeah and they said okay
well that seems like a very Mr Beast
thing dude it's just like money can
solve all problems
if you throw enough money at it it'll
fix it so sure I mean that that was like
the fairest most honest thing I could
tell them was like I'm not gonna be a
yes man or a no man I'm just gonna tell
you exactly how fuzzy it is yeah I want
to take the risk well as an engineer I I
hear like the three weeks delivery time
for the [ __ ] scale of this project
I'm like I would like to see this
project be attempted in Japan she's like
okay let me uh send the idea off for
approval you wait three weeks it takes
three months yeah
yeah but it was it was like the most
stress I have endured did they explain
to you how they got into this position
in the first place where they needed
this project delivered in three weeks
it's just
it was like squid game hype gotta do it
now as quickly as possible right they
set the deadlines and it's like then you
look at the show or the episode of Mr
Beast and it's like everybody else who
did something similar right like the
giant sets yeah or the bridge or this
and yeah special effects and it's yeah
oh holy [ __ ] you guys like
it was that's crazy it was easy it
really was yeah how was it seeing the
final result after seeing like what you
got involved with and just seeing this
like I think this is the biggest project
that's been on YouTube that has that
comes to my mind other than other than
Jimmy also doing the Willy Wonka thing
it's all just Jimmy stuff at this point
you know like I mean right but I think
squid game was like the first one that
really sets the level of what he could
do and like him just like completely
leveling up his content I mean didn't he
say that that video cost him more money
than the entire production budget of the
TV series or something I think it was it
was it was very expensive it was like
two three million dollars right yeah
something like that I think that it was
approaching or it was comparable like it
was in the same ballpark like it wasn't
exactly the same I don't even think it
was half yeah but it was much closer
than it should have been for a YouTube
video yeah yeah for a single YouTube
four or five million right I think it
was overall something crazy I yeah I
think something I can't remember hey
what's the production budget for the
no I did ask for more than they gave us
more but okay I because we had to spend
a bunch more money too yeah I was gonna
say I mentioned that initially you
probably gave an estimate that was very
generous but even then it's like okay
well overload shipping plus all the yeah
and it was all it's also weird like
being on YouTube and asking somebody for
an insane amount of money because like
every if any other person came to me and
asked me about that I'm like I would
just say no like the only reason I even
entertain the idea is because it was Mr
B's I'm like okay well if anyone's going
to be willing to pay what it's going to
cost to do this yeah that makes sense
yeah it's like we had to like mobilize
people that had like day jobs at like
Silicon Valley Tech companies which like
they literally like had to do that's one
of these secret agents
how do you convince someone who works at
a tech company who like has trouble
getting time off to basically play hooky
wow sure those I mean it seemed like
your team was pretty good though yeah
yeah it's very funny I enjoyed your
video about it I seemed like it you made
it seem a lot more chill than I imagined
it was yeah yeah
what was it like on the filming day like
it was chaos so like the first day went
horribly wrong right they threw the
whole day away it's not in the I didn't
put this in the video oh really yeah
we've got some sneak peek information
like there's a whole day that that went
wrong that they threw away and they
ended up paying all the contestants like
an additional I don't even remember how
much it was it was like I think a
thousand bucks each or something like
Jesus wait what wasn't wrong on the day
it the pacing was messed up because we
had built a the squib system and there
was another company that was supposed to
do motion detection all right and I had
I had like I had warned them I had tried
very much to warn them of like I don't
think that it should be done like this
but it was too late because it already
paid these guys yeah and
the way we like meshed the two systems
together was not good oh so just didn't
so the reason also the first day the
reason why I went back like that wasn't
used because the whole system was just
broken it was it was not broken but it
was a pacing issue that Jimmy wasn't
happy with because it felt like a show
not a competition if you wanted to be
like real time he wanted to be like oh
like you know green light go everyone
runs red light stops and then it's like
people start popping Yeah
well yeah it goes yeah so what was
happening was they would say green light
red light and then it's like this guy
that guy that guy that guy that guy and
it's like 30 seconds 45 seconds
it's like okay Papa and so it's like
dysfunctional like it just everyone's
like not holding still trying to hold
still and they're saying oh they're
moving this and so it just you know I
mean they did everything really quickly
three weeks but I would argue one of
those like 30 45 seconds of Silence be
cut out of the video anyway yeah but I
think that Jimmy likes it to be
realistic realistic and it also just
kind of I don't know it could be a weird
energy if everyone is sitting there yeah
I can see why you'd I guess uh yeah I
mean that's gonna be an expensive
decision though to push it back yeah so
what was the solution in there the
solution was they basically scrapped
that entire other system that they had
40 paid for oh wow then we we were lucky
because we had developed the IOS app
yeah which also wasn't even supposed to
be a part of the original plan it just
like that's a whole like almost well
it's one of my friends friends like
heard about the project and he started
just sort of making this it's a fun just
kind of for fun yeah and I saw it and I
was like yes I want a friend that just
makes iOS well it turns out it's like
like YouTube and Mr Beast and money are
a very good way to get people excited
like you you can pay people to do
something but you can't pay them to get
excited about it yeah that's true that's
true and that's like it's you know
people get kind of upset about that
sometimes of like oh I'm here to work so
that I can pay my bills and it's like I
get it but also if you are excited about
something the work tends up you know
ends up being oh yeah yeah it fits
everybody it's better if you invested in
it yeah it's better to be passionate
fixed all the problems so we scaled the
app from like six iPads to a hundred
iPhones and so literally we like maxed
out the developer account or we were
just like we spent an entire night just
programming iPhones over and over so
it's like USB you did all this in one
night a few hours yeah
so there were 500 iPhones because
everybody originally was wearing an
iPhone all the contestants yeah and that
was supposed to be the motion detection
but the problem was they started dying
yeah okay we were filming so long
I'm listening to this and I'm like yeah
we had an issue with our
um GoPros on bikes with uh because we
kind of just hoped that if you strap a
portable battery and it charges the
GoPro then it would work which worked
perfectly but there are some issues that
you just can't like predict yeah yeah
like when we were filming our drifting
special our GoPros were just overheat
because it was so hot yeah we just yeah
didn't have a solution so there was like
nothing you can do yeah I don't even
think they sell something that can
handle that yeah yeah yeah so just think
like hearing the story and just thinking
yeah we're just gonna like make a text
solution in like six hours and just kind
of hope that it doesn't that it works on
this three million dollar video I'm like
there's there's like part of me like all
of me is like like stress right now and
I wasn't even part of the part of this
project whether people just like
you know because obviously they want to
know when it's when it's going to work
where there are a lot of people being
like hey William when's it gonna be next
yeah so I I basically whoever like our
liaison there he's great yeah yeah
um and he gets it and he trusts me and I
trust him and so like there's really
good communication there where it's like
I'm I'm gonna be as literal as possible
like I'm not gonna be funky I'm not
gonna hide anything but there's a lot of
people who kind of are more TV minded
and I at that point I had such a short
temper
from all the stress yeah that I was like
the instant like somebody came like any
of their guys came to any of my guys and
they were asking stupid questions I
would just like I think they learned
like don't do not do not what kind of
things were that it was just like oh
like when is it gonna be ready when is
this one oh my God
it's like you guys like right now you
ever seen like videos like a raccoon in
a trash can yeah and they open the lid
it's like it's stuck and it can't go
anywhere so it's like it's really
aggressive it's like you've trapped it
yeah that was me yeah I was like I am
trapped in this this environment of
having to make this thing work I don't
know yeah [ __ ] if you have to wait 30
minutes I don't give a [ __ ] how much
would it cost you like go away I just I
just realized is it ready yet is one of
the most asinine questions to ask it's
like if it was radio I would [ __ ]
tell you it's the equivalent to are We
There Yet yeah you know or it's like why
are you asking that would you do it
again yeah
I I would say no unless I the idea was
exciting the idea was exciting and it
would it would have to be a little bit
more time like literally one extra week
yeah it would have made a huge
difference because there's just
something about like if you have too
much time you'll drag it out and if you
have too little time it's going to be a
nightmare like there's a sweet spot
where like you can start panicking at
five weeks and you'll get it done right
yeah if you have five years like why are
you gonna Rush yeah that's true just
like hearing the story it actually like
gives me anxiety it's like it's like you
know like you know that feeling where
you've gotta you've got a deadline the
next day and you haven't started your
dissertation until the night before it
feels like that but just for like three
weeks constantly the crushing feeling of
knowing it can't be done yeah I was at
home I think for like only a couple days
that whole three weeks yeah I think 11
flights where will you go I flew up to
San Francisco flew to Texas so Colorado
North Carolina yeah yeah I think I would
actually get like like nightmares just
like that yeah like I just wake up in
the cold swear I was like Jimmy's got a
request I was probably sleeping like
four to six hours every night which is
not a lot like
every night it was rough I mean like you
guys make you know like bigger videos
like when you have a goal to go do
something like imagine like when you're
doing a video failing is okay for the
most part because you know if I'm trying
to do this and you know oh like like
your car breaks down or something like
that's part of the content but there's
something horrible about about
engineering where not just engineering
but engineering from like a practical
perspective not a YouTube perspective
where it's like 500 of these have to
work yeah it's not like my video where I
can make it work and if it stops working
I stop filming and I fix it and then I
do like these have to work yeah they
have to work yeah
it gets the point where you involved in
a project like this and it's very
different from just making your own
video because you realize there's so
many different moving Parts whereas if
your moving part doesn't work that then
that affects everything everyone else's
things yeah but they've been working on
and it's just oh and then you're like I
know how much money they're spending on
this yeah yeah and I'm like I'm not
gonna be the guy that ruins it yeah this
is my senior design project in college
was this uh UAV it was like an airplane
that we were supposed to fly and you're
supposed to look at Targets on the
ground and yeah yeah and there was like
60 people on the team there's way too
many people right
um so I built this whole like image
recognition system and it was supposed
to like I never programmed it because
long story short turns out if the plane
doesn't fly because the team that was
supposed to make it Fly Just do a good
job then what's the point of all the
work
you know so it's like I'm not going to
be the guy yeah that doesn't allow this
video to take off like exactly not gonna
be me because we do we know actually how
much money you spend on that video yes
that sounds right yeah 3.5 million so we
won't even write it was 3.5 I thought it
was like 2.5 yeah how much was actual
squid game
it's a different thing entirely why are
you getting it I don't know you know you
know how sometimes you have a nightmare
where you like you go to school and
you're naked or some [ __ ] or you like
haven't prepared for this homework do
you think like Jimmy's team just like
wakes up and just like just wakes up to
a fake phone call with Jimmy or
something having like a request you're
fired